bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi diosono fa vigente oggi sono su un
video un po particolare mettiamola così
prima interamente che se in tantissimi
di fare la reaction ai miei video vecchi
che una cosa che si usa fare dopo un po
che sia un canale oppure una pagina
facebook insomma chi ha fatto un qualche
cosa che è rimasto negli anni come se
quando cagli uno stronzo poi i loro
commenti due anni dopo
perché è rimasto sempre lì il che sarei
io e non lo faccio ragazzi per lei
commenti del tipo è ma eri meglio prima
perché prima di microfono perché prima
aveva i capelli perché prima baffa
quindi ragazzi prove di vedere un
attimino un po di video vecchi per
vedere che cosa tanto hanno fatto un
miliardo quindi va bene proviamo dal
primo in generale prima di vedere allora
ragazzi il primissimo che era quello per
annunciare il nuovo canale gesù santo
che questo per vedere allora bella tutti
i ragazzi e benvenuti a salerno in testa
non alieno io sono fa vj sei veramente
fa vj zio come una pappardella ragazzi
vela risparmio ma comunque la maglia
foxhound wildtrack con questi capelli e
questa espressione potevo andare in
motorino senza mettere il casco costa
romano più seriamente
io direi che vale il pollicione il suo
al video solo la mia se saggina ed un
tempo regata andiamo un pochettino più
avanti qualche giorno dopo giacché siamo
partiti col sì che i piccoli colpi di
genio che ho per caso ho chiesto la
carta da cui lo zio solo perché prima
parlava di stranzi bene tutti i ragazzi
benvenuti a questo primissimo video del
canale di fa rigettato ragazzi la
qualità di questo microfono che aveva
era una cosa pazzesca finite che che che
suono puro cosa faresti se ti svegliassi
in un posto dove non si è mai stato
prima di sicuro non cercherei pagine a
caso però come il presentimento che
stiamo per andare a fare proprio quello
ma guarda che perspicace che sei sono
accorto che mi soffermo troppo in
diversi posti cercherà l'avevo messo
come una notazione vabbè dai stima
mettiamone volo un po più veloce le
capre che quello di prima era lungo 1 km
as
ok ok la cosa più spaventosa di tutto
questo non è lo spavento dell'horror ma
la maglietta di baci abbracci amico mio
c'è ma come ti vesti esatto esatto che
cazzo xd xd xd
che è uscito sto tizio sacco di volte mi
vengono a dire del tipo farina non fai
più giochi di una volta con la grafica
michia che grafica che avevano i primi
giochi che facevo proprio convinto della
a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo blog sono fatti per carità di dio
mettici due effetti di colore quando fai
video tranquillo è eccolo perfetto
questo volevo dire no a un altro
ascensore perfetto questo è stato
speciale 10.000 iscritti let there be
light
oddio oddio oddio oddio oddio oddio ho
sentito un rumore non è piaciuto no ho
sentito un rumore che non mi è piaciuto
guardare v6 giocando a un horror sei
tranquillo e normale vecchia vacca
quanto è figo del graggio già mi chiami
addio bella cosa mi fanno passare lido
stronzo di un cane perfetto c'è anche la
forbice che era quindi si può privarci
triste che io ho messo quel poster di
call of duty di sfondo perché pensavo
facesse figo cioè io l'ho tipo minchia
show al posto di call of duty sono un
gran gioco
in conclusione ragazzi in conclusione
c'è sempre la tua bellissima testa
passati una mietitrebbia in testa la sec
saggine con la camicia a quadri proprio
quattro ragazzi il telecomando è rimasto
sempre comunque questo anche a distanza
di anni cioè una roba ma il primo
episodio di happy per il primo video di
è più visto ragazzi cos'è miliardi che
poi si usciva pad o quasi 2 milioni di
visualizzazioni cosa è più e magasa td
meno zio che la droga non ancora
arrivata militato c'è anche la
possibilità di mandare avanti la
velocità che anche senza traccia senza
niente l'amisom distanza doppia con
inizio estate di brutto stronzo ma
abbraccia e guardando la camera si
sbilancia tutto bene bene bene bene
perché siamo siamo detti 100 occupati
dove ci aspetta per riuscirci
assolutamente jazz cafè non aiuta
votanti il massimo se non facevo tutto
italiano il primo di cat mario lega
fantasmi tutti grazie benvenuti la
storia
questa roba penso che non sia come uno
dei miei soliti video nel quale non so
delirio come un matto per gioco
abbastanza tranquillo in generale quindi
[ __ ] come ci ha preso questo ragazzo
tranquillo stai giocando a un gioco
incazzerei ma neanche per sbaglio
credimi è tranquillo liscio perché non
funziona ministeri perché i sottotitoli
che voglio vedere che cazzo tirano fuori
perché fare il dj cav'iggia in un
farisei ma che cazzo di sottotitoli suo
show l'ansia madonna volvo e carmine vai
bellissimo a c'è posta per fa vj era il
primo video in cui ha messo un altro
video in un giorno solo mio dio due
video in un giorno cazzo che cosa mi era
appreso a quando ho fatto 18 anni
fantastico ho fatto il mio diciottesimo
compleanno si perché io ho 18 anni anche
se molti mi dicono che non li dimostro
cielo sarà mica perché ci hai tipo una
marmotta morta in testa va beh ma quella
un altro disco portò registrando questo
log sempre col microfono nuovo che è
stato appunto un regalo di compleanno è
vero che sul piano con microfono qui che
sto ancora usando adesso a distanza di
due anni e mezzo cioè fantastico mi pare
che lo stesso cosa ma che sentivi e non
è vero era per fare il figo ma date
ragazzi questo era il primo pacco in
assoluto in assoluto meno arrivati
ancora altri un barattolo di nutella
nuovo al cosa che non mi avete mai
regalato ragazzi ma che cazzo manda a
casa un macchina che cosa è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi sto rifiutando di continuare a vedere
questo video 5 stelle sammontana ma
porca [ __ ] eva fatto che non lo
sapevo ho fatto ho fatto l'ho fatto con
famiglia e mezzo però c'è stato meno
perché niente ero andata a torino comics
ho fatto una foto insieme poi lui ha
scoperto che io facevo video bellissimo
melo gasato di brutto dunque ciao karim
ci vediamo poi quando esce il film conti
all asta cevo un tempo ragazze erano
solo or la faccio niente solo
esclusivamente horror odio questo erano
gli spaventi più
credo che sia ancora il primo in
assoluto di spavento più grande che mi
sia preso perché perché non me lo stavo
aspettando mai nella vita quando sono
arrivato a suo sfavore
fermi fi vi prego la foto di me da
piccolo con il pannolino di sfondo bravo
domanda ti riconoscono per strada si mi
è capitato ljubo quarda lo chef al vip
mica come ti sei montato la testa lorido
10 vuoi a concepire veramente quante
persone sono iscritte al tuo canale vado
a vedere perché non mi ricorda a questo
natale dell'indiretta quanti iscritti
averlo ma dai 90 7.316 96 micheletto già
al tempo e cazzo se mi mettessero
davanti a 97.000 persone ci rimane anche
là davanti a 50 persone ma neanche a 10
siete quasi due milioni i ragazzi ci
riuscirei che in sintesi non amico mio
ci avrei da realizzare dei numeri che
non sei neanche come si pronuncia
gli faccio gli screen deve stati persi
sono quelli di facebook 2545 messaggi su
facebook facciamo un controllo prima e
dopo terminati avere ragazzi non sono
così tanti sono soltanto due milioni
492mila 384 messaggi non letti e poi io
me la tiro perché non rispondo ai
messaggi ragazzi a prati questo uno di
questi giorni è venuto luca a casa mia
che è l'amico con il quale ho iniziato a
fare video su youtube insieme a nicky
box è praticamente abbiamo iniziato a
rivedere i video vecchie metto anche
questo nel reaction perché è stupendo a
parer mio
questa paghiamo questa non era nessuno
dei due personali ragazzi questo è stato
il video delle reaction spero che vi sia
piaciuto è stato alquanto strano
rivedere video vecchi ma è sempre sempre
veramente un pezzo di vita alla fine
perché dalle 17 in poi ho fatto prima
lo youtube quasi a tempo pieno quindi è
stata una roba non sto vivendo più negli
ultimi anni della mia vita cioè a parte
tutto il fatto di essere magari
cresciute quindi cambiato un pochettino
di carattere robe del genere non mi fa
cambiare come persona quindi è normale
che magari è un taglio di capelli
diverso e ringraziamo il gesù cristo
importante che si rimanga coi piedi per
terra anche dopo da ranghi e gli
iscritti e robe c'è l'importante questo
appare dai mia madre non mi chiama sony
cristo di volta che faccio un video
scusate un attimo pronto noi sa cosa sto
facendo
stavo giocando a carte con cicciolina
ciao ragazzi ammazzato perché se questo
video e non sa che una di tutto ciò è
anche cosa madre ma sta scherzando
ragazzi sto scherzando
quindi ragazzi ok spero che ha visto gli
sia piaciuto ragazzi cose il dossier
video è piaciuto lasciato argomento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
condivido tratta descrizione sono
divertiti scrittrici vediamo il vostro
video col classico del comando da
200.000 anni a questa parte ci apriranno
museo solo per questo coso vabè dalla
ragazza